[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos por la pandemia de
kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde nuestros
hogares para llevarles toda la
información -soy valentina torres
sánchez gracias por acompañarme
iniciamos esta crónica hablando del
consumer electronics show els es esta
gran feria tecnológica de las vegas que
tuvo que realizarse virtualmente por
primera vez pues las tecnologías para
combatir o frenar el avance del
coronavirus fueron una parte clave del
evento vamos a hablar de project heysel
una mascarilla inteligente que cumple
con el protocolo n95 cuenta con
ventilación activa que filtra el 95% de
las bacterias y se auto esteriliza con
rayos uvb su diseño es transparente y
tiene luminosidad regulada para que se
vean los labios de aquí en la puerta
asimismo cuenta con amplificación de voz
que vas cuando tratas de comunicarte con
la mascarilla puesta tu voz se atenúa y
es difícil escuchar por el diseño
hermético
rezo razer boys and resuelve eso
mediante un complejo sistema de
micrófonos altavoces y amplificadores
que contiene la máscara
nosotros tomamos la voz de adentro y a
través de algoritmo removemos cualquier
atenuación o distorsión y lo que sale es
sonido claro saudí saud otro de los
productos presentados en el ces fue el
club y ubide el y se trata de un robot
diseñado para eliminar los virus que se
encuentran en superficies de alto
contacto esta torre de desinfección está
equipada con luz ultravioleta de tipo c
la más potente cuenta con sensores de
movimiento por lo que esquiva obstáculos
y puede desinfectar una habitación en
entre 15 y 30 minutos el día ha mostrado
un robot específicamente para las
preocupaciones que surgen con la
pandemia y me encanta que estemos viendo
este tipo de tecnología en el ces la
robótica en general ha dado un gran paso
adelante en términos de cómo los robots
pueden ser útiles de forma autónoma en
nuestra sociedad entonces estoy a favor
de este tipo de tecnología vamos a
hablar de otro robot que hizo su debut
en el cese se trata de la última versión
de cure y un androide de compañía auto
y equipado con inteligencia artificial
que busca hacer un alivio para personas
que se sienten afectadas por el
aislamiento fue diseñado originalmente
para acompañar a adultos mayores y puede
dirigir actividades como yoga caminatas
y juegos de memoria cuenta con
reconocimiento de voz permite realizar
videollamadas y también reproducir
canciones y vídeos todo ello mediante su
pantalla táctil
gates yuri odia la soledad yuri es una
máquina que está absolutamente
disgustada por el nivel de aislamiento y
soledad que muchas de nuestras personas
mayores están experimentando en eeuu o
en francia pero es lo mismo en china es
lo mismo en japón y es necesario hacer
algo lo que hacemos es generar
conectividad de humano a humano donde
las personas por diversas razones no
pueden viajar y como resultado
simplemente no tienen suficientes
conexiones interpersonales
seguimos hablando del cds pero nos
alejamos del coi 19 porque otro de los
productos que causó sensación fue un
cadillac volador presentado por general
motors el futurista vehículo es capaz de
despegar y aterrizar verticalmente y
alcanza una velocidad de 90 kilómetros
por hora está diseñado para un único
ocupante y carece de controles internos
por lo que el pasajero puede disfrutar
la vista mientras se eleva por los
cielos se trata de un prototipo que por
el momento no tiene planes de salir al
mercado sin embargo el concepto se llevó
las ovaciones de los expertos
y vamos a finalizar en ucrania donde un
joven creó un proceso con el que
convierte las hojas secas que se han
caído de los árboles en papel
su nombre es valiente y fresca y su
método se basa en depositar las hojas en
una máquina especial que extrae las
fibras y las convierte en pulpa ese
material se lava varias veces y luego se
mezcla con productos químicos orgánicos
principalmente con almidón para darle
resistencia y suavidad al papel para
finalizar se dejan secar delgadas capas
del material y éste se convierte en
rollos de papel
esta tecnología es única porque hemos
aprendido cómo usar los desechos que se
generan anualmente y hemos aprendido
cómo convertirlos en un producto
intermedio fibroso que puede ser usado
en producción de papel somos los
primeros en el mundo que hemos logrado
hacerlo en términos de uso comercial
había estudios previos pero ninguno de
ellos había sido implementado donde
boudou la primera gran producción con su
iniciativa llamada we live papers
en 2020 y el papel generado se usó para
fabricar bolsas y paneles de huevos
ahora trabaja en perfeccionar su
producto para crear cartulina con este
método se requieren de 2 a 3 toneladas
de hojas caídas para fabricar una
tonelada de papel lo que en el contexto
tradicional requiere cortar 17 árboles
de tamaño medio las hojas acumulan
grandes cantidades de dióxido de carbono
durante la temporada de crecimiento de
los árboles cuando caen y empiezan a
pudrirse ese co2 es emitido a la
atmósfera sin mencionar lo contaminante
que es su quema o su compostaje nosotros
lo que damos el dióxido de carbono en
nuestros productos y reducimos las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
a la atmósfera bajos pero así terminamos
esta crónica recuerden que pueden
repetirla y ver otras emisiones en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]